what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 4 of the data visualization
applications with Dash and python
tutorial series in this tutorial what
we're gonna be doing is covering live
graphs so up to this point we've covered
how to do a basic layout and sort of
graph and then even have like user input
changing what that graph is but many
times you're gonna want to actually have
a graph just automatically update
whether you're doing something like
reading from a sensor or maybe you're
doing some updates based on some
database values or whatever there's lots
of reasons to have a live graph so let's
go ahead and cover that example so first
burgers are gonna make some imports here
so we're gonna import - so it can use
stuff from - from - dot dependencies
we're gonna import output and events so
unlike before we were importing just
output an input this time to update live
we don't need any actual input instead
what we're gonna have is an event that
triggers some sort of function that as
if an input like an input but instead of
an input it's actually an event lots of
times actually an input if you're doing
like UI really anything like gooey stuff
a lot of times a user inputs called an
event so it's kind of an unfortunate
naming convention there but that's okay
we'll just continue on but just take a
note that if you're using your imports
from before that you need event event
there and then import - core components
as DCC and then import - HTML components
as HTML then we're gonna import plotly
so it can use stuff from prot plotly
we're gonna import random just for the
making of random data for us to graph
and then we're gonna import plotly dot
graph objects
go for short graph objects and then from
collections we're going to import de
queue or de cute I don't know how to
pronounce it I'm gonna call it dick you
feel free to get me in the
section tell me how to properly
pronounce that if you want what did the
queue is is basically it's a container
that has a you can specify a max size so
you can basically think of it like a
list that you can say okay I want the
maximum size of this list to be 20
elements so when you try to insert the
twenty first two that basically was
going to do is is going to pop out that
zero element and then insert that new
element so it always keeps a maximum
length it doesn't have to be that length
it just has max so anyway X will be a
day queue with a max Len of 20 and then
we're also going to do the same thing
for a Y now we're gonna go ahead and X
dot append one y dot capital y dot
append one just so we have some initial
starting data now let's get to the
application itself app equals dash dot
dash and then we'll just throw dunder
name in there and then app dot layouts
basically we've seen this before so
we're gonna have a 80 ml dot div and
then inside here's where all of our
children will reside and that's going to
be a list and in there and in fact maybe
this would be better better than the way
I was gonna do that so we're gonna say
yeah I still don't like the way it's
done that let me do this one other words
act in that way
well you just really want to be a list
right there okay like I said styling the
HTML from within the from within Python
can be a challenge okay so anyways we're
gonna have DCC graph and this will be
the graph that we're hoping to be live
now we do need an idea if we're gonna be
updating this element because just keep
in mind all the updating that's gonna
happen is gonna be done via JavaScript
and if you've ever worked with
JavaScript if you want to update
something you pretty much need an ID you
could get away using other things but
it'd be very sloppy okay so we're gonna
use an ID for this so we're gonna say
live graph so we have the ID and then
we're also going to pass an animate
equals true here and that's really all
we need if you recall you know the other
thing that we're gonna need is figure
but we'll get there in a moment
so DCC graph good now we're gonna do is
also have an interval interval now this
is kind of an interesting little element
here what we're gonna have is the
interval and you're gonna specify an ID
for this thing now maybe we'll check
what this looks like in the code I'm not
sure we'll actually be able to see it
but anyways this is how we're gonna
trigger an event to occur for us
so we're gonna give this the ID of graph
- updates so mmm this is going to be
basically an event that has the ID of
graph - update but it's an interval so
what we're gonna say is we're gonna
we're gonna say the interval that we
want this event to occur in milliseconds
will say 1,000 so every one every second
or every 1,000 milliseconds this
interval is gonna run with the ID of
graph update so if you recall from
before when we did inputs the input
would have an ID and a value but using
that ID we you in the
a purr that we pass or the decorator
that's what we need to trigger some
function to run so if if you're feeling
comfortable with the input and output
stuff then you should probably know
already where this is going but we need
to make first that like that decorator
so what we're gonna say is at app
callback and so we're gonna make a
callback here and we're gonna say the
output the output is this live graph
right we want to update this live
whatever has the ID of live graph now
this time though we don't want to just
update anything we want to update figure
so so again this graph won't actually
show anything until we pass figure into
it so just just for the record I'm just
gonna pay something in real quick don't
write this out but this is what we're
expecting when we graph something so we
DCC graph it gets an ID which we must
have and then a figure and inside that
figure which is the dictionary we have
data and then if you want to you can
pass layout and stuff like that so
keeping that in mind let me just comment
that out again you don't have to write
that I just want to show it to you and
bring it to your attention okay so any
call back here okay we've defined our
output now what we want to do is the
events so what we're gonna say is events
equals and this will be a list of again
the event type and then what was the ID
of that event well its graph - update so
as you can imagine there are other
updates or I'm sorry other events that
you could come up with it just so
happens that the event that we're making
use of right now is just this interval
class basically that just simply calls
this ID every one second but there are
many other events that we could use here
this is just one of them so event is of
the ID graph update and it's an interval
and then what we're going to do now is
define the actual function itself that's
going to run so we'll just define
de Graaff and again we can call this
anything we want because it's actually
the wrapper itself that is being called
and if you're familiar with decorators
lush wrappers it kind of it's almost as
if it's encasing the function within so
it really doesn't matter what we call
that function it's the wrapper itself
that's going to get the trigger to then
run the function so once we have that
what we want to do since we're just
using some toy data is update that data
so I'm on a global X and global Y so I
mean you might be squirming or whatever
because you're told Global's are the
devil if it makes you uncomfortable I'm
sorry
this is just a toy example like I said
normally maybe you'd have an SQL query
here or something like that select for
all from limit 10 order by you know time
descending not in that order
anyway you'd have something that's
updating this data or maybe you're
reading from a sensor and then you're
storing the data somehow whatever I'm
just going to do it this way for the
sake of simplicity and then let's just
add some data so we're gonna 4x X is
just our x-axis we're going to just do X
minus 1 plus 1 so we'll just keep adding
one to this X element and then what
we'll do is something similar for y but
not quite the same otherwise would be
very boring so it'll be the last Y
element plus the last Y element times
random dot uniform let's do negative
zero point one two zero point one cool
so that'll just kind of add a little bit
of randomness to how our data looks at
the end of this one so once we have that
now what we need to do is we want to
build data right we want to build this
bit out so what we're gonna say is that
data bit will be plotly dot and actually
I think we're going to use graphic yes
let's just use go here so data equals go
daunt
scatter so it's a scatter plot and then
what we're going to say is
x equals list capital X y equals list
capital y let's not forget our commas
there so you can't pass into queue here
you have to pass a list so we're just
going to convert it the last second to a
list now what we want to do is let's
just give it a name host called scatter
and then we're gonna get dude thank you
now we're gonna give it a mode and we're
gonna say lines plus markers so in
plotly there is no like there's nothing
called a line graph it's just a scatter
graph that happens to have lines
connecting the scatter so that's your
line graph so lines plus markers gives
you a line graph so once we have that
basically now that's the data bit in
here right that's this but now what we
want is basically all of figure and
that's what we wanna stuff into this
graph right here right that's what we
want to end so now I'm just gonna return
this stuff so I'm gonna say return and
then what we're gonna return is a
dictionary right this right with this
first value being data so we're gonna
return
I think it's lowercase yeah data : and
then as you'll see it's a list of
elements so let's just do a list of the
elements with this X&Y and types and or
not types but names and mode let's say
we want that to be a list so we're just
gonna list data okay so that's covered
so we've done this part right now we
need layout so let's go ahead and pass
the layout lay out
and layouts gonna be a little different
now what's the reason why we have to do
this is for whatever odd reason when you
animate a graph with plotly it doesn't
want to like refresh the entire graph it
only refreshes the data points within
the graph now this becomes problematic
when you exceed whatever the starting
axis values were so let's say the axes
went from 0 to 10 what if you have X of
11 12 13 well as that graph updates it
just goes on right off the graph it
doesn't actually update so what we want
to do is we want to have this graph
update those things now if anyone from
plotly is listening which I doubt why is
it that way don't make it that way but
anyway go dot layout like to me the the
animate equals true ought to have this
basically run every time instead we have
to make it run every time so that's what
we're going to do we're gonna say go dot
layout and then what we're gonna say is
we have two words gonna set the
limitations for the x axis and the y
axis so we're gonna say x axes equals
dict and then range is going to equal
and then we give the you know the the
end the bottom and the max or the
minimum and the max max x okay hopefully
that okay cool
so now we need to do the exact same
thing for the y axis so y axes min y max
y now on some plotting mm frameworks you
would probably want to add like a little
bit of leeway on both sides like I don't
know 10 plus 10% or 5% just so you can
fully see things I feel like with plot
Li you can still clearly tell where
things are so I'm not going to add any
more to that but just know that
sometimes you might have to do something
like that
anyway okay so that's everything right
that's layout it's the dictionary so
that was every that was like all of this
right we're returning figure because
this outputs to figure of live graph
here
boom that's everything we need so I'm
gonna go ahead and get rid of this and
now we just need to run the app so what
we'll do is just do the if dunder name
equals dunder main app dot run server to
bug equals true awesome let's run it so
what happens invalid syntax it looks
like clearly like we forgot a comma
let's try again
whoops
try to pull it down anyway looks good so
far let's bring this over refresh
there's our empty graph okay and it's
updating now and as we can see the
x-axis is updating we haven't okay now
the y-axis is updated as well and we can
see the live graph has begun and then
once we get to 20 data points we'll see
the entire graph shifts as the min and
Max for the x axis begins to take effect
there we go and as the day queue just
gets rid of the initial stuff obviously
you could make some modifications here
and you know you don't have to have a
max Len of 20 you could have a max Len
of you know hundreds if you really
wanted so the other thing is you could
update much quicker or at least you
could attempt so we'll try a hundred
here just wait for it there goes it's
just going to start over so
interestingly enough that doesn't appear
I'm pretty sure that interval is the
same it definitely reset itself but that
interval feels the same I wanted to show
you that it does actually go faster than
one second this is clearly still on one
second maybe we have to fully restart or
something like that I don't really feel
like doing that but you you can get this
to go a little faster but I feel like
sometimes it gets a little behind itself
and I don't really think especially if
you're reading sensor data or anything
from a database just make sure that it's
updating as quickly as it seems to be
reading in so I don't know have any idea
how the back end is working with with -
here I just I've gotten the impression
that sometimes the data is baha or
what's being shown
is behind what it's like cashed or I
don't know in the pipeline to come out
so I feel like it probably does get
delayed over time if you make that
update too quickly so someone can feel
free to test that but just be weary that
that might be a thing anyway regardless
that's it that's a live graph and now up
to this point we have everything we need
to build that app I showed you before at
least all of our knowledge of - now
we're just going to put it all together
so the app that I showed you in the
beginning basically reading vehicle
sensor information we're just going to
generate dummy data just like this so
everyone can follow along you don't have
to hook it up to your car or anything
but something like you know picking
things from the menu getting graphs to
dynamically pop up given which one we
picked from the drop-down showing you
know dynamically one which will
fullscreen it or maybe two so it's like
half the screen or three or if you add
more than three putting them on another
row that kind of stuff
hopefully just kind of bringing together
everything that we've learned up to this
point so if you have questions comments
concerns suggestions whatever feel free
to leave them below otherwise I will see
you in the next tutorial